ça se fait par équipe chaque équipe
reçoit une carte sur lequel le tracé
dessiner à l'équipe de parcourir ce
trajet sur ce trajet vont trouver des
bornes avec des questions auxquelles il
faut répondre et la le temps mis enfin
différents éléments donne des points de
pénalité qui servent ensuite à faire un
classement et il y a deux types de
challenge de challenge 10 compétitions
qui fait partie de championnats de
France des rangs de challenge et
découverte qui est ouverte là à tout le
monde
[Musique]
alors c'est des questions qui sont
relatives
principalement à l'observation du
terrain et des questions relatives à la
ville qui nous accueillent c'est à dire
qu'on donnait auparavant une petite
documentation sur la ville qui nous
accueille et évidemment des questions
sont posées dont les réponses sont dans
cette documentation
[Musique]
le trajet cette fois-ci cette année
c'est dans la forêt des clés et le point
de départ sera de la ville des clés et
les trajets font une douzaine de
kilomètres à peu près
[Musique]
jusqu'au dernier moment on peut
s'inscrire une heure avant le départ nos
problèmes les départs sont échelonnés
donc les premiers départs ont lieu vers
9h jusqu'à jusqu'à 11h à peu près